we start today with Republicans in
shambles as what they expected and
believed would happen at the U.S Mexico
border when pandemic era title 42
guidelines expired did not happen the
Border was not overrun as biden-like
border patrol laid down it would
whatever hypothetical insane conspiracy
theory Republicans believed was going to
transpire did not transpire but let me
tell you what is going on Bloomberg
reports border crossings
fall 50 percent easing fears of U.S
migration surge surge the number of
migrants seeking to cross the U.S
Southern U.S border has been markedly
down during the past two days bucking
expectations of a surge after pandemic
era border rules expired the U.S border
Patrol quote has experienced a 50 drop
in the number of encounters versus what
we were experiencing earlier in the week
before the restrictions known as title
42 were lifted it's too soon to say
whether the numbers have peaked border
agents reported about 6 300 encounters
on Friday 4 200 on Saturday that's down
from a record high of about 10 000 a day
early last week so there's a couple of
different things that are important to
talk about here first what are we
talking about when we talk about title
42 title 42 was not created by Trump but
it was used by Trump as an emergency
measure in the context of the pandemic
to more quickly turn around those
undocumented immigrants encountered by
immigrations enforcement agencies like
border patrol instead of a longer
process before they could be deported
and sent back to their country of origin
title 42 allowed to allowed it to be
done more quickly now I don't want to
focus on the obvious absurdity
of the very same Republicans who said
kovid's no big deal
on the other hand on the other side of
their mouth saying covet is such a big
deal that we need to enact an emergency
measure because it's so big a deal we
need to turn around undocumented
immigrants instead of giving them the
due process that they normally get let's
put that aside because that's beyond the
scope of this conversation the
expectation that we've been hearing is
that the Biden border policy is a
disaster it's essentially no border we
don't have a country anymore you know
you've heard this stuff before
uh and thus when title 42 expired it was
just going to be a deluge of who knows
hundreds of thousands millions of
undocumented immigrants rushing over
what actually happened is that the
number of encounters declined now
there's another aspect to this that I
think is important to discuss which is
that of encounters as a sign
that the Border policy is being enforced
or that it isn't one of the things we
heard endlessly from Republicans was we
know tons of people are getting over the
Border because of the number of
individuals that are being stopped and
countered and stopped by border patrol
Marjorie Taylor green would often say
look that we now have a hundred thousand
encounters a week of people that are
being stopped the border is broken and
of course if you were thinking clearly
and rationally you would say wait those
people are being stopped that means it's
not an open border and then they would
come back and say well no
the number of individuals encountered
and stopped is a proxy for the number
that get through this is an argument
they made by their very standard
if now we are seeing the number of
encounters decline dramatically by their
logic the number of folks that are
getting through without being stopped
must also be declining dramatically
again this is not me saying it this is
by their own logic will they acknowledge
that no they won't instead what they're
focusing on is that when Biden was
interviewed riding his bike over the
weekend he said he doesn't currently
have plans to go to the border and in
fact when you listen to the reasoning he
gives it kind of makes a lot of sense
things are going at the border sir
much better than you all expected do you
have any plans today I think pardon me
do you have any plans to visit the
Border not in the near term no no it's
just be disruptive not anything else
yeah
why aren't you going to go to the Border
well it would just be disruptive that's
absolutely true Republicans love to
pretend that the only way to manage the
situation on the border is for Joe Biden
to go and to do a photo op and to
inspect the Border fence and this sort
of thing why do they think that well
because that's what they expect from the
Republican politicians who do those
types of photo ops all the time they
bring a desk they put it so absurd the
visuals they bring a desk and put it at
the border and sit there and say we're
meeting we're meeting with border patrol
oh but really what you're doing is
you're actually creating a lot of
logistical work for security and all
travel all these different things the
allegation initially was when title 42
expires it'll be a disaster
it hasn't happened now they're shifting
to why won't Biden go to the border and
Biden rightly says because it'll just
become a distraction we will continue to
follow the story but as usual one of the
areas in which they lie the most is that
U.S Mexico border one of the best ways
to support this show is by supporting
our sponsors today one of those sponsors
is sheath underwear it is spring
temperatures are rising many of us know
all too well about the sweating and the
sticking and the chafing but that's only
when you use traditional underwear when
you use sheath underwear it's no longer
a problem sheath underwear is
ergonomically designed with separate
compartments in the front to keep
everything dry cool and separate and to
keep you comfortable they come in a
zillion different designs something for
everybody the quality is amazing super
long lasting put an end to the
readjusting and the sweating and the
shifting uncomfortably sheath underwear
is really a lifesaver you will thank
yourself it's a unique product you've
got to try at least once to see for
yourself and my audience gets 20 off
with
go to sheathunderwear.com Pacman the
link is down below